thing i want to talk about the gambling
thing okay talk to you about it
and like oh yeah
gambling is like gambling is a very
damaging vice it's addictive
and it's uh very damaging
one of our one of our employees here
love got got
wrapped up in in cs go gambling when he
was a young kid and it really
covered up like the cs go slow like the
fight yeah
he knows all about it your buddy banks i
think he owned i think he owns one of
the sites
no he did i think previously he did on
one of them yeah yeah cs go wild ask him
he knows about it
okay god but anyways um the thing is
like even though it's your own money i
think the problem is that no it's not my
own
right right sorry i meant to say even
though it's not your own money and
you're very upfront about that which is
good you're transparent so that's good
but the problem is is that
you are you know one way or the other
there's a reason they're paying you
right
because you're out there playing you're
getting people
interested you're you're driving traffic
to their site with the promo code you
are sending
people who you don't know how old they
are you don't know their financial
situation
and most likely they're pro it's
probably illegal too depending on
what state they're in there's not many
states where it is actually legal
you can only yeah it's it's not legal in
the state actually i think it's legal
that's why he that's why he flew to
mexico to gamble
from mexico right but yeah but you got
to understand that the the
having your the audience watching you
gamble nothing good is going to come out
of that for any of them it's all bad
it's all bad and there's a reason why
you have to be 21 years old to gamble
it's it's a vice it's it's when you're
too young you can't handle that that
stimulation you can't handle that
addiction it's very
very very dangerous
100 percent nice
thank you i mean i
you know i look at that as another i
didn't i didn't think about perspective
you know like people that watch me
you know if they're if they see me with
something crazy put in 100 you got
thousands why can't i do that i know
what you're saying like that's another
side
i didn't really think about so got that
mexico internet
are you in mexico right now no i'm not
right now i'm not it's actually like
well
my oh am i breaking up but i know you
know i understand at the same time
like you were breaking up for a minute
but you're good now i mean i i everyone
saw that leak dm where you're saying you
get like two million dollars a month
so like i understand that's a lot of
money to turn down right and you know at
that young age too it's hard to be like
20 bro like yeah
like that i'm so new to this dude like i
know and i might look
for any type of symbol like at all but i
have a i have a sibling who's really
really sick
and like when i see that when i saw like
no way like i've never seen much more in
my life yeah i was like
yeah i was like dude it's it's insane
but you gotta know there's life-changing
you know yeah so but there's a reason
they're paying you that much money right
that's not
that's not money out of thin air no yeah
no not i mean of course i'm expecting
you know them to make money on top of
the money to give me of course but like
you know but with as clear as i make it
with as transparent as i make it you
know
i just i try to just let everyone know
that you know it's not my bread
don't do it guys you don't got the bread
to do it but i know what you mean but
like
that's like saying this though and look
you say gambling's an addiction let's
look at another diction like alcohol for
example right
yeah you can't do that to your 21 either
right
right so that like can is that a good
analogy if i use alcohol i mean not
really because
i would say the like to go into a store
and buy alcohol you need to be 21 they
check your id
to gamble um especially on those
websites all you use a crypto wallet and
you can like [ __ ] totally
yeah i'm trying to think of another
analogy off the top of my head
like the biggest problem i have with
that stuff is that there's just a lot of
young kids getting involved
influenced by it yeah yeah no i do see
what you're saying bro
but i mean we say something comparable
to gambling probably like the most
comparable thing is probably like
crypto how is crypto
comparable because crypto is gambling
it's influence gambling but it's not the
same as actual gambling game
yeah gambling like it's not the same as
like pokemon cards for example you know
what i mean there's like a layer of
separation gambling is a game of chance
that you
are making repetitive actions you're
getting hits of dopamine
and you're going to lose that's the
whole thing right kryptos
it is you have like tons of different
emotions throughout your whole entire
body like it's just open yes
and it's a lot for a kid you know but
like again i totally understand because
that money's insane
i do congratulate you you do i love the
stuff you do with like all the
influencers and
and like musicians and stuff is super
cool i think that's awesome
and i really appreciate that brother
thank you i mean i mean i
i know i know you and i've never had a
star first time having a personal [ __ ]
like
a face-to-face combo i didn't want you
to think i'm like some like snotty kid
like i
like i i really do like i'm literally i
learned from my mistakes bro like if i
if i [ __ ] if i [ __ ] up you know
i don't ever want to make the same
mistake again and you know like i said i
i think it just puts me
in a it gives me like a more like i
don't know like it's
i'm learning a lot bro i'm honestly
overwhelmed right now in my life
because i'm just it's so new to me you
know what are you done gambling
um i think we have one trip
lined up after one lab no
oh [ __ ] are you hey are you going to
come out for only loud miss
wait are you going to run loud come pull
up let's hang out
dude i would go rolling out in a second
oh god really
yeah i'm down wait when is it um a man
of convictions here
it's july it's friday it's just coming
up coming friday's the first day
wait can cutie cinderella come i know
you're a big fan of her
i actually like i i like her bro when i
was when you know when me and rice were
going at it
she had my back i had her back well we
can agree
you know aiden do we both agree that
rice got a giant douche
oh oh
it depends how you mean by that
i think in every way i mean that in
every way yo this is housemate
that's his housemate ethan watch out
he's probably the one holding the phone
all right
he lived together bro what are you doing
look i
you know i'm gonna stick up for him of
course you know i live with him
you know man he he's the one who kind of
got this content [ __ ] going bro like the
house
i can't i can't really just sit here and
talk [ __ ] about him you know he does his
own thing bro
um you can hate him personally you don't
have to like him bro but one thing i can
tell you is you know he's
he's a different breed bro he's a
different breed when it comes to his
content
so different well anyway um
i don't know what that means how long
have you been
unlocked how long have you been
streaming because it is pretty amazing
how
popular you become like uh in such a
short time
uh in senior year my high school bro i
i wanted to i started streaming and i
was very on and off
and uh and then towards the end of the
year like i missed out on my prom and i
missed out like a bunch of like
senior activities like the field trip
days and all that stuff like
i just wanted to stream i almost even
skipped my own graduation for bro i was
like so determined and locked in
um so did that how long's that
i graduated 2019 so two years okay wow
so you've been at it from for a minute
although did you just recently get
popular or because i've started
to see my password said i had to kiss
corinna to
to be somebody did that really wait
i wanna i wanna ask him about this uh
real quick like
why do you get so mad when people say
you're a normie streamer aiden
dude i honestly when i was first just
like coming into like
you know like being like talk to about
with you guys and stuff was
very thrown off i was like why are they
picking on me bro
you know like dude you want to know
something i love you guys though now i
understand your humor
yeah what's up we're normie streamers
man all right
when you have anything over like ten
thousand viewers you're a [ __ ] normie
everyone's in norman in my
normal right now uh it's hard
i mean yeah yeah it's hard for missy if
they speak right now he's a guy you're
dick in his mouth but
he's he's letting it out what do you
mean no it's not true
so it's not true so what's not true is
it excuse me a normie streamer he's just
[ __ ]
you know dude yes 100 we have a vip
here damn it we're not talking about xqc
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is
right these are we are the yeah thank
you so aiden
now that i've got you here thank you i'm
sorry guys um
so are we going to continue so now that
we've kind of talked about the gambling
thing
is this something you want to continue
or is it something you're planning on
winding down
you make me rethink about it now bro
honestly like i don't i'm not even just
saying that like
it's just something i that just doesn't
click right for me you know
it's gray for sure you know i've just
never seen this live channel money in
front of me in front of a table like
that
you don't have to get it i get it i get
it it's it's just definitely something
bro like
now i'm gonna think about it's like
you're you're right you're right bro i
don't want to put i don't want to
jeopardize it well it could be
it could be he's going to think about it
on his plane trip to mexico
yeah pretty much to do it to do his last
uh
you know to do his last game living
stream
because what he's saying and funny terms
is that
your wealth in that regard is ill-gotten
because it's
made on the backs of of what's prob
likely children's money
that they've lost the gambling sites
yeah no
and i'm going to tell you like not like
okay
so when i was like 13 bro
i just played this game i think it was
like 10. i played this game called
i play two games i just play wizard101 i
used to play runescape
right and uh i don't know if you guys
heard those games
i think still
yeah you have yeah i know of runescape
though
of course gold for gf yeah whatever yeah
i explained runescape a lot and i would
buy gp i would buy money
and i would take my [ __ ] dad's credit
card and just buy money with it
like i used to do that [ __ ] all the time
bro you know what i mean
yeah so um
so i know what do you say so you think
of it like that where kids are just
taking their parents card and it's all
good
yeah i think you know i and again that's
something i would never ever encourage
you know
but you never know kids kids might do
that because they're influenced by
what's going on my twitch stream so
that's just something i definitely have
to consider bro right exactly
exactly i don't know man
are you still donating to the lg
community aiden
i am indeed sir i'm actually right now
uh we're trying to
find a community that wants me to donate
my percentage so
but yeah so i want it
also it's not the lg it's the lgbtq
community
plus plus okay pretty good
just give me one more one more time nah
man i mean
is there communities that are not taking
your money because you said you're
looking for people that want your money
is it possible that they just say no we
don't want your money
no no i just don't wanna i don't wanna i
don't wanna put a chunk of money into
something like i wanna talk to the
people yeah
i don't know what's going on like i
wanna you know i mean like i don't but i
have people working on it so
yeah i'm keeping my promise and it'll be
he wants to suss it out
exactly do you find it do you find it
homophobic at all like the whole that
your whole get
like i don't i wouldn't say it's your
whole gag because i do think
the part of the gambling thing is that i
think you're so talented in other ways
i hate to see you making your money in
that way but you also have another joke
where you kind of like the joke is that
like you're suss
or that you're like hitting on people
and pretending to be gay do you think
that is homophobic or worse that's
he has no comment no comment at this
time sorry you dropped out
uh you're can you guys hear me uh i
think ricegum is pulling out his
internet again
yeah i think rice gonna fall nice yeah
we can see you now you're gonna get out
you're good you're good i can see you so
i think
i think if i answer that speaking about
somebody you know who happens to be
a part of the lgbtq plus community i
can't do that i'm not in their shoes i
feel like that's very ignorant for me to
say yo
no that's not homophobic because
somebody might be offended by that right
you know that watches me
so i can't i can't say that however i
can tell you that
i will and never and no matter what i'm
doing
content-wise i'll never ever sit there
and hate
on somebody because of their sexuality
you know because of their race
religion etc right so oh
so when you so let me ask you this if
you've got like a dude there and then
you start to pretend like you're hitting
on him so what is the joke
well no there's no joke i would just say
it's like it's funny to me it's just my
humor like for example like
right like everybody in hassan and miss
kip's chat types in omegle for example
right
i don't know what the [ __ ] in a mega lol
is i don't know what that is right but
however
that's their humor so it's like i don't
get it but
it's it's their humor we're known as the
pogers community
all right i'm going to be i'm going to
be donating to some omega lol's
megalo charities soon after that
so what's the joke though what's funny
about it
oh no i mean i wouldn't like all right
so back in high school
i mean sorry from cutting out the
internet is so awful
good i've been able to stream at this
house in two weeks bro um
so i would just you know
back in high school i used to just mess
with all my friends like
you know i would uh
i would just like i don't know probably
i don't want it to sound weird like
you hear me yeah yeah we can hear you we
can hear you
my best i would just like say like
you're hot you're cute like i want to
[ __ ] you like just as a joke bro
you know me to my friends like and at
that time obviously i would be seeing
girls so
i don't know it's just something i
always did in high school would you
would you try it out would you test the
waters
only with you a song would you snack on
you no but like i mean i mean seriously
like where are you
or miss no miss you too okay now we know
you're lying
okay really look at me jack harlow does
this a lot right
like jack harlow does what you're what
you're uh doing a lot but
when he does it there is a different
vibe to it because it's like he's doing
it in a non-problematic way
you know what i'm saying like where you
know that he's not making like
being gay the butt of the joke
whereas uh you know there's a there's a
better way to do it and it comes from
understanding and it comes from learning
about
uh you know the the experiences of
marginalized people lgbt people
where you know you you get to you get to
understand the plight that
some go through and then you can make
better jokes about it
you know what i mean hassan hassan
saying you gotta kiss the dude a little
bit
his internet cut out he didn't hear any
of that no i did i did
hassan can you hear me yeah i can hear
you i was just so lost in how good he
looked like
your arm was like amazing
he's getting sucks on you it just means
i'm bringing you
around now look being real fussy but
i'll kiss you back i'm not like i'm not
like the [ __ ] rappers you have on
your stream they're like oh dude shut
the [ __ ] up like i'll come over there
and kiss you right in the mouth
[ __ ]
nah but i uh ethan
what happened you're not
talk about me i'm sorry if you saw
anything that looked like a snotty
little kid or whatever but i don't think
you're a
little kid i think you're a shrewd
businessman who's making a shitload of
money
i think you're talented i think what
you've achieved is amazing
but i see someone who again you're 20
you know i don't know if i would be able
to resist that much money at your age
so like again taking everything in
account but what i see is a dude who
is you know looking the other way to
make a lot of money that's what i see
and you know it's wrong i mean come on
well what's wrong the gambling the
gambling
well you well it's not a hundred percent
wrong it's great
it's not black now it's gray meaning you
know
it's mixed it's like it's a mixed thing
i mean it's controversial
i wouldn't say it's 100 wrong is it
illegal yes
not mexico yeah not in mexico but we're
all your
world legalities the same as morality
anyway yeah again there's a difference
no legal doesn't mean it's all right
yeah i was just i was
making a joke i agree i agree no but no
but it is wrong
it is wrong okay so let me ask you this
in what situation is it right
um if they have extra money lying around
like for example let's just say all my
bills are paid
i have money in my savings i just got i
just found 100
on the floor maybe i want to just put it
into a [ __ ] slot machine do you have
demographics on the age of the people
who watch you like
do you know have any idea how many
people who are under 21. i want to say
it's anywhere between eighth
grade and college students but you never
know i might have someone smaller might
just
i don't know yeah but but range do you
guys have do you guys have that
demographic
i'm not familiar with twitch stats yeah
i do
people live out their age though that's
the issue right right mine is uh
i think 16 25. we we know aiden ross's
demographic because he went to universal
recently
uh and uh you know he
we a lot of people came up to him uh at
universal they were
a lot of younger pretty young so i mean
i can send you the
he's saying the the w spammer uh clip if
you want to see
i didn't see the clip but i trust you so
if any of these kids that come up to you
at universal if these are
if i don't know like you know i'm
assuming there's a lot of young kids
watching you as as all of us
so i mean you know that ain't right so
it's like
you gonna say yeah there's some people
over 21 who are gambling
but then there's a lot of people under
21 who are even younger than that
gambling
does that mean that well look it's a net
bad i mean it's a net bad
i know what you're saying i know you're
i know you're i know you're trying to
say
and um you know it's just like it comes
into question it's like
it's not i'm making it very clear it's
commercial it's obviously yeah
every you could tell there's a banner up
in everything right i'm not
gambling away my money i'm making it
very very clear you know
so a lot of viewers don't realize that i
yeah i think you're underestimating how
stupid the average viewer is oh like
most twitch chatters are so dumb
and they have no idea that you're even
sponsored and they're just
ignorant and they came from tick-tock
and they really have no clue what's
going on and they see you and they're
like damn
i love this guy he's gambling he's
making money oh [ __ ] they're really
ignorant and
it's just how it is so h3 let me ask you
a question
go ahead my brother
really good friend of mine his name is
train wrecks he gambles with his own
bread right yeah
so is it different to gamble is it
different from
it is it the same do you look at that
the same where you look at it
differently i don't think the
well first of all i didn't know that you
weren't gambling with your own money it
does
it it does change a little bit just
because
the the reality the reality is is that
if you were playing with your own money
you would be a lot more hesitant right
but then you're like really feeding into
the like the mania
of gambling where it's like i don't care
about losing it but no the fact that
your brother
well look i don't think they're gambling
if you're over 21
is a vice we all know like anything else
and it's fine
right it's entertainment it's fine
obviously it causes problems for some
people who become addicted to it
you know it's a vice and just like other
vices
you don't want people who are not mature
enough to to get involved in it
because they're not emotionally and
mature enough to handle the
the stress 100 yeah but that comes but
that comes into where
you know if okay so you say i'm seeing
i'm seeing what you're saying i see what
you're saying
you know i don't plan on gambling my
entire life i don't care
i don't plan on streaming gambling my
you know my entire career
it's just more of something i took bro
because i wanted to i saw the like i
already explained to you like yeah i
saw it bro like i'm 20 i'm 20 i saw that
much money on the table my god damn
i could finally you know buy my people
stuff i can finally take care of them
and like miss said not everybody who
watches me you're right they probably
don't think that's
probably like is that like is that
sponsored like they ask me what time so
but that's not but that's even that's
not even the issue the issue is that
it's the gambling itself really but let
me ask you a question ms
you used to do gambling and then you
quit why did you quit doing the gambling
sponsors
uh i i i well if you wanna know my
honest reason why i quit
uh it's because i saw uh some of my mods
doing it when i was offline and they
were
losing money and i said to myself if i'm
seeing these guys losing this money like
this
and they're live losing this money um
and i know that there is some 16 year
olds out there who i'm not going to name
who are getting interested in it and
trying to make a crypto wallet and
they're watching me
and i'm like okay so now you're telling
me that these dudes are
you when you finally see it you're like
holy crap and i felt very guilty because
the reality is i make
way more than enough money to do
whatever the hell i want you know um and
seeing those
my viewers this this happening to them
firsthand
i was like damn i can't do this and i
know um one of aiden's brother's train
wrecks
does gambling too uh he's my big brother
hayden's brothers
he's my big brother so i i i i felt
guilty and i made it
i didn't need the money so bad bro i
don't know sorry guys this is so old
that's all right it's okay
i mean it's fine we're working through
it said what do you think about what
miss kiff just said about why he stopped
i see it now bro i really do and again
you know this is just not something i
want to
okay you're breaking up completely he's
pleading the fifth it's ricegum
okay he's back how about now you know
yeah you're good yeah you're good
so again i have a current i have a
current deal right obviously
and the deal is pretty much almost
up you know i plan on
probably not taking that again really i
just want to
i'd be very proud of you if you didn't
take re knew it would you look at me
differently if i didn't take it
i think so yeah i would be i would you
[ __ ] me old man
i'm just kidding yes
well you're rich enough to pay me you
can be my sugar daddy or well you're
younger i don't know what that means
is it reverse sugar baby yeah that's a
reference anyways
not ethan you know again
i don't see myself doing this for that
much longer no
to answer your question no it's like a
heist
because here's the thing i also in and
out it's it's it's well the difference
is no the difference is with the heist
like the bank is fdic
insured so people aren't losing their
money
the difference with this is like little
kids are [ __ ] you know stealing
mommy's credit card and doing [ __ ]
crypto
wallets like setting up cricket walls
and like gambling and being like i'm
going to be exactly like ayden ross you
know what's up
actually you know what's crazy about the
crypto wallets too is that like when you
would take your mom and dad's card
and buy what'd you say you were buying
like uh
runescape money yeah because that's a
credit card purchase so you can actually
get that reversed and stuff and deal
with that but crypto [ __ ] has just gone
to the void that's like bye
smell you later yeah
no it's not going out of the void it's
going to work directly in the pockets
of whoever is doing the rug
you said that you want to make the money
so you can give it back to like your
people right
like your friends and [ __ ] it's like you
can like be like yo i got you after like
all these years and [ __ ] and i'm the
same way and i feel you because that's
what i want to use my money for
right come here real quick come here
this is my buddy i've known him since
the uh the third grade
does he pay you is he hooking you up
pierre i have uh my buddy from the third
grade
i got uh i'm about to uh about to get a
house somewhere i'm not gonna say
obviously apart
and i have my buddy not him another one
of my buddies that i've noticed in the
third grade
live in that house and then i'm also my
other friend
his name is luca he's like my assistant
i just put him on payroll as well
you know i just love taking care of my
people i came up with these people but
it's coming forever
let me ask you a question isn't it
counterintuitive if your fam
what you call your chat is losing money
and then you're just giving it to
another part of your fan which is your
third grade friends
but it's not there it's not listen again
ms i know what you're trying to do a
little [ __ ] listen listen listen
they first of all who's that right there
yeah oh
this is uh russell he's my lawyer
russell what's up russell
what's up buddy wait i'm wearing your
heart thieves uh gucci right now by the
way
wait i wanted to hear i wanted to hear
your your your answer yeah
so i want to i want to say what i want
to say oh yeah you know
i've had incidents where people have
come to like literally my house before
they've cried in front of me like you
know they open up to me about stuff and
i always take time out you know to talk
to anybody that comes up to me i want to
hear everyone's life story like
i don't i don't ever i look at us all
wrong yeah what the hell
that's not biz no like this story it
really makes me feel emotional too
honestly
i feel that
well he's lagging very badly
aidan i would say to you i'm gonna wait
for him to come back
hey i want to save you i want to say to
you that you're big enough
you're popular enough you're talented
enough popular enough let me say that
again
you can make a [ __ ] load of money
without the gambling dude look at miss
kip that kid's rich as [ __ ]
hassan
you don't need it and ethan and ethan
i'm going to say it again
you want to you want to be there let me
tell you something as the old [ __ ]
man here right
you're 20 years old you don't want to be
reflecting and have
ill-gotten money dude you want to look
back and say all that money i made is
legit nobody could say [ __ ] to me
because right now you everyone people
can sit [ __ ] on you
all they want because what you're doing
all right all right all right let's wrap
it up because i really do that i gotta
film this thing
but look you're right i'm on the phone i
do not listen
listen um okay get up okay
i don't wanna wait for this yeah i'm
wrapping it up he's wrapping it up miz
get in here
sorry that's my third great friend
hey mitch why are you not doing the
eyebrow cut again dude i i'm on it i'm
on it i'm on it all right i i i get it
done brother get it done you look you're
influencing you're you're influencing
little kids again to do bad things
you're right with the eyebrow split
dude no people love this slit man aidan
you and i are a lot of like man we're
both garbage human beings
[Laughter]
yo go ahead and i want to hear you wrap
it up i won't hear you close it up so
i'm going to wrap it up really quick
again i don't plan on resigning you know
my my whole deal
i don't you can't tell it stop it now
just stop it right now [ __ ] it
yeah that would make you respect you a
lot really
if you just don't respect that too if
you just tell them you know what
this isn't right i'm i can't do it
anymore now that i would respect
the problem is the promise is a six
person deal i assume and
face banks and rice gum and all of them
are also in on the deal and he's the one
who gets the most views so if he doesn't
do it then he [ __ ] over
everyone else who gives a [ __ ] you gotta
do the right thing bro
he's not in a defense by the way not
only that dude i
so i actually backed out of a gambling
deal because uh
i was like i don't want to do this
anymore i backed out of like two or
three months ago and they threatened to
sue me
good luck with their illegal company
right well it's still it's it's it's
scary so
i look i understand why you're the right
thing about it anyway
but it would be that it would be the
brave thing to do anything to do ethan
ethan i gotta make sure
it's it's done the right way correct so
the right way is stopping as soon as
possible
okay but it's it's almost done right how
much longer
i don't know ethan you want to come to
kabul if you do yes you do know how much
longer you said it's almost done
that implies you know how much longer is
left in the deal so how much long's left
in the deal
i do not want to come to cabo with you
it's a nice
chance we could [ __ ] why not
no see look look he keeps saying this
you're going to have to catch a dick if
you keep saying this that's all i'm
saying
okay you're actually going you can't you
know you can't
[ __ ] ethan looks ethan looks beat so
i would not [ __ ]
well don't worry the feeling's mutual my
dude
i'm fresh ethan's married ethan's
married no
wait wait wait wait i'm serious now
aiden how much longer do you have left
on this contract because you're talking
about me
you wanted me to respect you right or
maybe maybe you don't care about what i
think about you but in general
people do care about this so how much
longer do you have on your contract
it's not it's not that i don't care what
you think about me but when i when i'm
when people just send me stuff like yo
he's talking crazy
i just want to see your heads i hope now
definitely look at you look at me
differently to where you don't
really go around you know bad mouthing
yeah quit now and i will respect you
can't quit now then i think then then
you're [ __ ]
turning your head and making blood money
jobs not finished
if you recognize that what you're doing
is wrong with respect to
uh you know getting kids uh to go out
and gamble or like showing how sick
gambling is
listen it depends and you know it's
wrong
it depends how you look at it yeah of
course people you can rationalize
rationalize anything away my dude
people have made hundreds of thousand
dollar gambling you know what i mean so
it's like
wait no no no that's terrible that's
that's literally the problem that's
gabriel's fallacy bro that's how you get
through trolling you guys always troll
i'm trolling back
okay but we're not but this is serious
you know so so yeah when is that so how
much longer you have on the deal
what can i learn how much longer you
think why won't you tell me one more he
said he has one more mexico trip so he's
got to do like one more of
you know one more big like always with
these gamblers yeah exactly one last
problem
are you are you talking [ __ ] right now
you know who's really down bad i'm not
throwing my big brother train
under the bus but that [ __ ] is
down
what is that he's got to make his bread
back i don't blame him so i don't give a
[ __ ] about him he's also a piece of [ __ ]
with peace and love
hey hey don't don't say that about him
well he's gambling he's selling it i
mean
listen you gotta own what you're doing
you're doing shitty stuff
all right trey's audience is like older
and way more decent than anybody
let me back it up i don't know anything
about train other than that he does
gambling so
i'll back it up i don't know anything
about him but what you're doing is very
shitty
it's gray it's not it's completely oh
bro stop you're deluding yourself
it's [ __ ] up so what
it's great i agree it's it's we're not
agreeing
it's black
anyway you're saying black is bad
well when we're talking when we're
talking about a more scale of morality
and where white is good and black is bad
which you've established
yes black is bad i just want to go play
minecraft man that's all i want to do
listen it was a pleasure
pleasure talking to you just know that
i'm going to own up to all my mistakes
getting paid are you going to own up to
them when you're done getting paid
that doesn't sound like owning it you
know what you're doing is wrong stop now
you kind of did that with a milf token
too where you were like yeah that was
dog [ __ ] bro like i can't believe you
guys bought it right
he literally did that in the beginning
hassan you you
pay attention to all analytics you i
know you were on that i used to watch
you when back when the election was
going on bro you pay attention to every
[ __ ] statistic at
every minute of the day through that
after i did that [ __ ]
it went down so listen it was not
pumping up nothing right so look what
i'm trying to say is this i made it very
clear from the initial start
hey guys i mean i played you guys the
clip but look
aside from the ethan already said let's
drop that that token yeah
let's talk about the gambling part one
more time i'm going to say my
aside from it again
i got people to take care of dude you
make enough money
stop hold on a second hold on you don't
need that you don't need two million
dollars
if it went up let me talk you gotta let
me talk yeah go ahead go ahead
go ahead so listen listen bro
i think it's something gray but let me
ask you a question
if i'm drinking alcohol on stream right
like and obviously kids watch me yeah
like no because you're not you know dude
it's
just not it's obviously not the same you
don't have a promo code on your stream
that's the only analogy i can think of
well it's a bad analogy so i don't know
what to tell you
we'll work on it yeah we'll work on our
analogies getting people getting people
hooked on alcohol or getting kids hooked
on alcohol is also bad except like
if you were you're not making you were
doing the alcohol
equivalent if you first of all you can't
even do it because it's like literally
illegal
yeah this is a legally gray area that
you're taking advantage of despite the
fact that you know it's morally
unacceptable because you've already
admitted as much
but if you were doing the alcohol
equivalent of
what this gambling is like what you've
been doing as far as like the gambling
streams
you would literally be [ __ ] guzzling
like fireball every goddamn day for
subscribers or some [ __ ]
and the the reality is which would ban
you immediately yeah and you would have
a promo code
you would be like go buy fireball i'm
making money off every sale of fireball
i love fireball
and it's also like your liver you have
like a fake liver where it doesn't hurt
you
so and it's like it's actually not
actually not really you're not really
drinking fireball you're like
that that's the analogy in the alcohol
oh [ __ ]
yeah i can hear you i don't see myself
doing this long term i'm going to stop
very shortly
i can't just stop right now because what
ms was saying
you know i don't want to run into any
trouble so
it is what it is okay if you knew it was
wrong you would stop immediately we
obviously don't see eye to eye on that
but i would be very happy for you so
that's
like look i i'm seeing your view yeah
i have a different view it is what it is
you wouldn't be flying to mexico if you
knew it was like legally uh
correct it's not even legally the thing
that you can do you're like
avoiding you're starting legal
responsibility right but we're not
talking about legality we're talking
about morality
morality in the gallery aren't you
saying you know what you have it's
what i'm saying exactly if you just
heard a song say that like 30
[Laughter]
very glad you called in i think it's
great we connected and props to you
coming here because you knew that you
know
you're coming to the lion's den so to
speak so that's very
so thank you for calling i think it's
really cool more courageous than steve
crowder
yeah exactly and i'm glad we connected
i personally just i i uh you know i
never got a chance to talk to you and i
know you see clips about me or you might
see stuff about me
you know i just don't want you i want i
wanted to get a chance to talk to you
and get to know you personally
so i don't know how you feel about me
now
i thought how do you feel about it how
do you like
how much you like me 1-10 i was going to
say i think you're cute but i don't know
no what would you say like me 1-10 now
that we personally talk
i don't think we would hang out i don't
think so either you're like yeah
but i'm just saying but i'm just saying
like how much do you like me now
i mean
i mean on a person it's always nice to
get to know someone on a personal level
i see you as a human being and not some
random you know person that
but but but you know what what do you
want me to say i think you're doing a
horrible thing
so do i like you no not really
you don't like me i'd [ __ ] you don't
crave validation from people aiden
i'm gonna explain why it's like i'm very
authentic with you
i'm telling you everything that's what
you want to know well you know so did um
you know uh like ah god what's the name
of uh
you know being authentic doesn't mean i
need to like you i mean you're you're
being honest but that doesn't absolve
you of doing something horrible that i
don't think you should be doing
ethan you know i've never seen you smile
before do you have a soul
i don't do gambling online
i mean i would say more evidence of
having a soul is happening
online to determine if you have a sword
well because you have no problem uh
peddling gambling to children and that's
a more soulless act than
than not smiling wouldn't you agree
it's fun okay fun for you not for them
it's a good one in general it's fun if
you make two million dollars a month
it's a lot of fun
i'm not telling kids to pull
their lives savings on
it i'm sponsored stop you you you you
you're deluding going back and
but i respect i respect you coming on
but do i like you
no is that okay with you
i just don't understand but there's
nothing i can do to you know i would
like you
and respect you if you quit that
contract right now i would embrace you
and say aiden
you broke dogs now you broke up what'd
you say i said i would like and respect
you
all the way if you quit that contract
right now and i'll embrace you as my
brother
i love you but you're not going to do
that
it's already almost over h3 he said that
thank you
it's almost over and
amount of time
what it's almost over it's almost over
he was just joking it is almost over
yeah we're almost done
how much time left
almost done yeah exactly all right
checking in rolex watch
take care all i'm gonna say all my these
days look look i think
i think you're uh deep down aside you're
a nice person
but uh you're you're losing yourself a
little bit in
the game of clout and also money
okay why because you seem like uh
because the gambling yeah gambling
crypto whatever
who knows what kind of opportunities
might come down the line and uh you
might take it
so it's it's as people who have been in
the content space for a long time
especially ethan like
i don't know we're just uh we're just
trying to see this as like a
positive uh reinforcement to move you in
the right direction
rather than a place where you know
you have a flame and then you burn out
and then all the people remember you
is a guy who did like crypto scams or a
guy who did like
who peddled gambling the kids and a guy
who like fake called cops and you know
what i mean like that sort of stuff i'm
sitting next to him right now by the way
by the way um i like what hassan said
i i i think you're a nice guy in person
you know i'm sure you're very friendly
and nice so
when i say i don't like you it's not
because i think like you're not a nice
guy and good to hang around i just don't
like what you're doing just
because i like the way hassan said it
better so look you might not like
like what i'm doing exactly but do you
like me as a person
no you just said you liked me no i think
you're
nice you're being 220 years old right
now i
not to be super ageist here but like
you're looking for his validation
like i do i want the reason it's not
gonna work quit now
and i will validate you i will [ __ ]
validate you all the way but that's not
happening
aiden have fun what are you planning in
mexico what are you gonna do you've
taken private down there
nah cut first class
business business nice staying in a nice
place
living large it's a nice spot [ __ ] yeah
what city cabo you said
yeah what are you a fed i'm not sorry no
i'm just trying i just i
do that yeah i'm just trying to know
what you're doing oh my heart you
no i'm not trying to talk to anything i
just want to know yeah
i just this dude's ordering
yeah ethan i just wanted to make you
laugh man you look like you needed it
thanks bro think about it like this
think about it like this
okay you know the whole cop stuff like
the cops coming up
and someone swatted you for sure like
they actually spotted you
no i know the the swatting was real but
then the fake cops weren't right
this guy right and and you know you know
that when you do stuff like that right
your audience at first gonna you're
gonna get a big boost from like 12 year
olds we're like oh
pogba's whatever looking not even right
away because right okay
like people will people will boost it
but then they're gonna be like well this
guy's a fake he's doing like youtube
cloud [ __ ]
and it's kind of like that with gambling
as well where
you know your your audience is going to
get older you're going to get older and
then people are going to
remember you as a guy who just did like
every [ __ ]
bad meta out there that jumped on
you know the token for the crypto [ __ ]
i already learned to never do something
like that again
this is like it's sellout behavior you
know what i mean you just think you know
that's true so look and that's another
thing i wanted to
sell behavior like you're spelling out
your family i
your fam 100 i'm working i'm working
with a whole new team right now to where
they're going to make sure that i have
the right guidance to never even go down
a route like that
because that's what's supposed to be
all right yeah aiden
i don't want to be authentic and real
aiden yo
yeah it's breaking up i just want to
wish you well i don't want to hold you
up i know you got to go
enjoy your trip and thanks man and
danny can i say something before you go
man of course
look you and i are very similar man and
i i just hope you i hope you get better
okay you could do better
um i'll see it really loud by the way
i'll be are you actually gonna roll out
i'm down to go right now if you're going
i'll hit you up
you're lying to me no i'm not i swear
i'll take the next flight i got you i
will go to wrong loud
why not i just i'm not four years old
like like h3
i'll go there what is that painting in
the background is that an orange what is
that that's me dude that's i'm an egg
that's not you it is me hey aidan do you
like mrs shirt
yeah cool cool aidan if
if miss gift comes to rolling out don't
let him irl stream okay
you have to you have to bully him
because you have more viewers and he'll
do it he'll let you [ __ ] iros from
the entire time
look at his streams for like 30 minutes
okay i'll so i'll just go live after
that listen
i'm gonna say this i think you're i
think you're a young man you know you're
20.
you've seen a lot of money in front of
you but do the right thing
we're like the the council at the round
table here we're trying to
just help you out a little bit do the
right thing damn it we gotta do what we
have
to do hey you know we should do ethan we
should do a full podcast
us for and then we have all my roommates
in too
it sounds like a whole that's something
like a podcast that sounds like a
[ __ ]
hold up dude that sounds like a wait
ethan hold on that's that's mom's
basement dude that's
that's big time that's [ __ ] mom's
interesting about mom's basement that's
probably
where most of these kids are actually
gambling from wait are you
friends what are you and keemstar
friends
oh my god oh my god friends hello
no no we're not friends you know
dude yeah oh wait you wish
h3 no i'm not friends with keemstar
why not so frustrating we're all you we
don't have the time for all that
we don't have time are you friends with
keemstar aiden are you are you good
friends
with keemstar i feel like
that's good steak stay close truthfully
you
[ __ ] clown you know be honest
now h3 go ahead if i answer that you're
not gonna like me
no i don't care there's plenty people
are friends with keemstar i was just
gonna say the best thing you can do for
your career is just kiss up the keemstar
because he'll never out you for
the scams you're doing he'll have your
background
scams brother he's got your back on all
this [ __ ]
right now i thought he was going to be
like keemstar sucks i was and he didn't
want to say it never mind he is
he is friends i have one question
of course he is go ahead all right
so like you you really think i'm a
scammer
i mean that's real nerd behavior if
you're like gonna be on the timeline
talking about how you're friends with
keemstar that is real l nerd [ __ ] right
there it's uh
automatically i like team i've never had
a bad interaction yeah that's the thing
i mean
people people say that about like uh
whatever i don't want to talk about kim
he's felt boring
um aiden what would you want to ask me
oh my god dude you are an affiliate and
you're going after everyone's throats
you are going to be getting
boring is that going to get me is that
too far dude you
you are going for everyone at the top
right now and you keemstar's at the top
of
[ __ ] what keemstar
sounds like a like a truffle pig for
you know the worst kind of people
team is cool with me that like i'm cool
with him yeah you know yeah i don't care
about it
anyone does as long as they're nice to
me
do you like him no dude
what are you kidding me why why would i
be listen
absolutely not okay my man is wrong on
literally everything if there was like a
i feel like he sits there in whatever
[ __ ]
basement that he streams out of
mathematically figuring out like how to
be wrong on
every issue never been right in his life
who laughs like that that [ __ ] is funny
as [ __ ] and if you
don't hate all the ones of the lg
community it wouldn't make up for it but
did
you want to ask me something no i'm just
saying do you do you like me now
i yeah yeah i mean this is gonna be like
a two-hour thing dude
yeah he said yeah all right guys peace
out i'm gonna go watch the new drama
alert dude have fun
hey [ __ ] mr the son see you boys later
eat the nice talking
nice chalk talk nice talking no
chopping it up with you nice chopping it
up with you
and man
don't talk [ __ ] about me that was the
best time of my life
easily that was the best time of my life
thank you ethan
that was i believe i think it was a
productive your your
first day on twitch and you've already
what a great first day on play
dude you went out with a a string on a
stick and you caught the biggest fish
and you reeled that thing in that was
insane your first day on the job thank
you well you set that up for me so that
was all but i mean
and hassan was in there you were great
uh miz was chilling but came with some
zingers
me i mean uh hassan you were fantastic
too
oh thank you well you know you're you're
very good at uh
keeping people on on point ethan